get ready to swoon because blake shelton
pulled out all the stops for his vows to
gwen stefani
he wrote her a song and he sings her a
song on tuesday's today show
carson daly who officiated the couple's
oklahoma wedding over the weekend
revealed the country star performed a
song during his vows to his new wife
and gwen she wrote her own vows too at
the wedding gwen starts
and she wrote this i mean like since i
was a little girl blah blah blah
and she crushes not a dry eye in the
church
we are all like and it was so perfect
that i said flake when she was done i'm
like top that butt
well the 45 year old country crooner
accepted carson's challenge
and blake starts by saying you know
gwen's always giving me a hard time
about
not writing enough songs yeah so i wrote
a song
guitar comes in frame stool next thing
he wrote her a song and he sings her a
song while he's crying that he wrote
specifically for her
uh reached the star i think it was
called wow and not a dry eye in the
house oh my gosh
and that was really a highlight but was
the song any good
according to carson it was a hit of
course
like the the radio guy i'm like that's a
hit song yeah
i don't think he had a name for it i
text him last night and i think he wrote
me it's called reach the star was the
working title
hopefully he'll record it carson said
the couple's vows were just
one of many sweet moments from the
intimate wedding which
blended both of their signature styles
it was perfectly them
you know the whole weekend and the
marriage itself it was
as elegant and refined and cool as gwen
is and it was as
country and down home and fun as blake
is and
they they just work they're an unlikely
pair you know they're they're like if
you paired
delicious fried chicken with a glass of
champagne
you know like on paper on the menu it
doesn't seem to work but it's
it works they're comfort food with class
and everybody roots for that
as for his role in the ceremony the host
of the voice said he couldn't have been
more honored to be the one to marry his
longtime friends
went for 25 years i was friends with
them both when they met separately i
love blake to death he's like
the brother i never had and then to have
the opportunity when they called me i
know where i was they both had me on
speakerphone and they said you know we
just
we think it work we think you're perfect
for it gwen and i both share a deep
sense of faith
we talk a lot about faith the two of us
and um and to work with them and their
family to get to be a part of that day
with my
family was really an honor i mean it was
just it was fun too like i don't want
people to think oh big celebrity wedding
right we had a blast all weekend long
carson doubled down on all of that on
instagram
where he shared some snaps from the
ceremony including
this pic with blake grinning ear to ear
as
gwen made her way down the aisle the tv
host captioned the post
quote here comes the bride so honored to
get to marry two of my favorite people
on earth
may god bless you guys in this new
chapter of your lives
we love you it's very emotional as for
the love birds
on monday the 51 year old grammy winner
took to social media to share the first
picks from their wedding day
check out gwen in her custom lily white
vera wang
silk gown with a plunging sweetheart
neckline driving around in a golf cart
with her groom
and that's gwen in her vera wang party
dress
that's the couple in their wedding
attire standing outside against the
sunset
and that's gwen and blake sharing a kiss
next to their three-tiered wedding cake
the caption july 3rd 2021
dreams do come true blake shelton i love
you
the couple has never been shy about
gushing over their romance while
speaking with e.t
in case you need a refresher here's some
of their sweetest moments
i think i'm his biggest fan i learned a
lot from gwen
sometimes i just feel like i'm in a
[Music]
dream